hello and welcome back to game review my
name is Caleb Denby and today we're
gonna be going over a game between
Jeffrey Zhang and Ray Robson from the
2019 spring chess classic of course the
spring chess classic is coming up once
again here in 2020
perhaps it's already going on by the
time this video airs and so we're gonna
be taking a look at the winner from last
year Jeffrey Zhang managed to win that
tournament and we're gonna see how he
fared against the one and only Ray
Robson the game started with Knight f3
d5 d4 Knight f6 and now after c4 c6 we
have a Slav by trans position now there
are a lot of haters out there that say
white shouldn't play C takes d5 because
the exchange love is notorious for being
prone to draws there's some some real
equality going on here
and it can be difficult to kind of try
and prove an advantage try and win the
game once you take this d5 pawn the
structures just going to be very
symmetrical black shouldn't really have
any problems developing his pieces and
so it'll be difficult to win however as
we'll see Jeffry managed to prove
something in this game both sides
started with very natural development
Bishop f4 now black takes the time to
play this a six move white plays rook c1
getting this trick to the open file
quite early on and now since white
hasn't applied too much pressure in the
opening black is totally safe to develop
this bishop out to f5 of course the only
downside to this move in openings like
the sloth is sometimes this b7 pawn can
end up just a little bit weak so you
have to be a little bit careful of this
in the game though Geoffrey first
started with III black plays e6
and now Geoffrey does actually go for
this Queen b3 move putting some annoying
pressure on b7 and now there's a couple
ways that black has responded to this
historically one funny-lookin move is
the move rook a7 this is actually a
pretty common move in the Slav to defend
this b7 pawn the rook looks out of place
on beasts on a7 but you can imagine
someday this pawn might come to b5 and
the rook can easily swing over to some
better squares on the C file also
playable for black is this move
Bishop d6 when you get a pretty
interesting line after Queen takes b7
where black is going to be playing
Knight a5 and uh-oh it looks like you've
trapped your queen but no need for
concern this has been played before and
this is actually a Queen sacrifice by
white in this case so this is one to
look out for if you're playing with the
white pieces perhaps add that one to
your book of tricks but in the game
Rey actually did none of the above
instead choosing Knight h5 attacking
this Bishop and here it's actually
totally fine for white to take this b7
pawn because now the bishop and the
Queen together controls c7 but in this
case Geoffrey opted for something else
simply playing Bishop e5 ray hits this
Bishop with f6 and takes this bishop off
the board with Knight takes g3 and this
was the point of a raised play here he
just wanted to get rid of this dark
squared Bishop white captures this night
with H takes g3 opening up this H file
and now white is actually making a
threat in this position you you wouldn't
really expect it from the the opening
here but white actually has a pretty
serious threat so black is not able to
just develop naturally if you do this
you're going to run into this move
Knight h4 when this bishop has no
squares to go to on this diagonal it has
to come to g4 of course if it comes to
g6 Knight takes g6 is going to win a
piece and after Bishop g4 96 is already
going to be crushing blacks position
here
rook g8 is forced and now for 1 this
pawn is hanging for 2 white can also
bring this Knight to a very nice square
on f4 when there's pretty serious
threats to Black's
Center so black has to do something
about this Knight h4 threat he cannot
develop naturally there's a few things
you can do in the game ray chose bishop
g6 but he actually ended up under a
little bit of pressure and I think a
better move for Rey might be this g5
idea it permanently shuts out this
knight h4 plan and it kind of locks
these two pawns on on these squares
where the going to remain doubled well
see in the game Jeffery was able to fix
this pawn structure and I think g5 would
have been a nice
to keep these pawns where they stand
instead we saw Bishop g6 now Knight age
4 is a good move from Jeffrey this
Bishop draws back to f7 and now of
course by removing this Bishop from this
nice diagonal White has regained the
ability to develop it's to develop his
Bishop to its most natural square on d3
black plays the very nice f5 trying to
lock this Bishop out of the game and
then I'll let you try and find Jeffrey's
crushing positional move here there's
one move that kind of stands out above
the rest that solves a lot of White's
problems all right hopefully you found
it at home there the move is of course G
for fixing White's pawn structure by
pressuring this f5 pawn of course it
would be a huge mistake
to take this pawn because Knight g6 is
going to come through with devastating
effect once again you can take this
Knight but after the check this pin is
too much if you move this King up you're
gonna get crushed on the Queen side so
you cannot take you cannot ignore it
because we've made a pretty serious
threat here so in the game raid shows g6
however this isn't the most combative
line probably what Rey thought he could
do here is play the move Bishop e7 and
at first glance this looks like it works
for black you're hitting this Knight
white does not have time to simply take
this pawn because they'll lose a piece
but in this case G takes f v is a very
very good sacrifice for white black does
go up the piece but after we take on e6
take on e6 take on b7 this Knight is
hanging this pawn is hanging and
Geoffrey is getting an astounding one
two three pawns for the piece and a
fourth pawn to follow quite quickly with
this h7 pawn it is not long for this
world even if white doesn't take it
immediately so Bishop e7 does not get
the job done either that's why Rey had
to go for this slightly weird-looking g6
move now after G takes f five rake
captures back with the e pawn and now
this bishop is going to be forever sad
on the f7 square not much future for
this Bishop in the game Geoffrey simply
reroutes this Knight
back through f3 and Rey finish this
development with Bishop d6 we see
castles and castles now in the game
Jeffry tried to reroute this knight back
from e2 perhaps into some squares on f4
on the Kings side perhaps a bit better
for White is actually to keep playing on
the Queen side here he has a little bit
of a lead in development with this rook
and perhaps playing on the Queen slab
like this was better 92 though was nice
to stop this f4 idea now ray plays on
the Queen side with Knight a5 we see
Queen d1 and then some strange
maneuvering was done in the game and
when after Queen f6 Geoffrey brings his
queen back up to a 4 highlighting that
this Queen on d8 was covering some
important squares like simply plays
Knight c4 and now Geoffrey once again
moves the Queen back to c2 putting
pressure on this night and trying to
make some headway on this C file with
some b3 threats
95 was black's choice and now Geoffrey
plays a very very interesting positional
sacrifice here I'll ask you at home see
if you can point out blacks best minor
piece there's one minor piece for black
that really holds everything together
and White's position would be much much
better if it were gone of course the
piece I'm talking about is this bishop
on d6 this Bishop is the problem piece
for white it's stopping all of his entry
on the C file its guarding all of these
squares making threats with f4 and
preventing these Knights from getting to
their most natural squares of course
this Bishop is the piece that is the
problem for Geoffrey and so it makes
sense here that Geoffrey plays Knight e5
and with impunity offering up a full
pawn sacrifice to black here in exchange
for getting rid of this bishop on d6
black plays Bishop takes e5 we see D
takes e5 Queen takes e5 and now of
course the c7 square is ripe for the
taking and Geoffrey does take it with
Queen c7 black has to take this Queen we
see rook takes c7 of course the Queen
was attacking this night as well and now
ray Brad sneaks a bit of a mistake
probably best for riot was to simply
defend this pawn which gives him the
time he needs to move this night off of
a 5 on to the better square c4 in the
game though we saw rook c8 Jeffrey
responds of course with rook c1 keeping
control of the C file we saw it takes
and takes and now ray actually went in
for the positional sacrifice himself D
for offering up the D pawn in exchange
for opening up this bishop and allowing
this bishop to take on a 2 so we see
Knight takes d4 bishop takes a 2 and
then this gives right or gives Geoffrey
the opportunity to regain his pawn with
the move that you probably see for
yourself B for removing the defender of
the b7 pawn ray brings this Knight back
to c6 and now Geoffrey simply captures
and captures and now after a5 saving
this pawn from from capture between the
two white pieces Geoffrey actually has a
very very nice endgame here in fact it
might be technically winning of course
that endgame is not after the bad move B
takes a 5 trading off pawns but after b5
and when this pawn becomes passed it's
very difficult to actually stop this
pawn from simply running all the way up
the board and becoming a queen black
plays a 4 here trying to create counter
threats with his own pawn but simply b6
and this pawn is difficult to stop
ray tried rook b8 getting in front of
the pawn but now the nice move Bishop a
6 comes through and white is already
threatening to trade the rooks and
promote in the game black went with King
g7 trying to prevent rook c8 from coming
with check so of course now this could
be countered with rook takes b6 but now
after b7 it's impossible to stop white
from winning material here ray tried
Bishop d5 now rook c8 would be winning
the game where c7 would be winning the
game and Geoffrey's move as well also
wins the game we see rook c5 you cannot
take on b7 because rook c7 check wins a
full piece instead we saw Bishop e6 and
only now Geoffrey play
is rook to c8 and Ray goes in for the
simplified endgame where he's simply
down a piece but the son game is not as
easy as you might think here this a pawn
is passed and it's very far away from
the Kings side pawns and so after King
f6 Geoffrey has to devote his Bishop
entirely to stopping this pawn we see f4
king f2 from Jeffrey and this is good
place so far he's doing the best he can
to keep the black King boxed out now a3
Bishop c4 and we see the problem for
white here it's true that he's up a full
piece for a pawn but this Bishop is
going to have to be totally locked to
the the Queen side here preventing this
pawn from from cleaning there's no
comfortable way for white to bring the
King over to win this pawn because then
black has time to trade off all of the
Kings side pawns with a draw so in the
game black tries h5 this is a pretty
good at drawing attempt you want to get
these pawns up the board and trade off
all of White's remaining pawns and this
is the way black and try to draw the
game
Geoffrey went for a takes f4 check King
takes f4 g3 check King f5 Bishop a to g5
in the game we see King III and now
black plays kingi v and this is a very
tricky idea for black here now there's
actually only one move that maintains
the win for Geoffrey Zhang here I'll let
you at home try and find it see if you
can pick out the only winning move okay
hopefully you found it a home of course
it is not f4 check that move draws it is
not g4 that move draws it is not passing
that move draws it is of course Bishop
b1 you need to cut this King off from
coming to the Kings side and now you can
easily win this game the what's the
problem with f4 I hear you asking at
home well of course black simply going
to take this pawn bring this King to f5
and now he can use this H pawn as a
decoy drawing your king away from
offensive the f-pawn and black will be
able to take your final pawn if you play
Bishop b1 check now black does not step
backwards with the losing position but
instead steps forwards and now it's true
that you can advance over here but black
is going to advance on the Kings side
and this like I said is simply going to
be a draw in fact if white isn't careful
he might lose this game King III is now
actually required for white to be able
to catch this pawn so that's why the
other moves are not good enough this h4
threat by black is pretty strong but
Bishop e1 is enough and now h4 does not
get the job done
white can simply capture this play f4
check and what's the difference here
well the black King isn't able to come
to g4 isn't able to keep the pressure on
this F pawn and white can simply collect
this comfortably in the game black did
not try h4 ray chose King f6 instead
trying to keep his chances alive but now
it's it's much easier for Geoffrey to
follow through
simply king e4 and after some bishop
maneuvering wasting Tempe the White King
is able to invade and after Bishop a to
Rey went ahead and resigned here of
course after age 4
White is simply collecting this pawn and
with the extra Bishop King and pawn n
games are always going to be winning in
fact maybe I'll show it for you just for
fun of course the idea is one you can
waste MP with the bishop and to the
bishop actually controls some key
squares here and the pawn easily
promotes in this endgame a very nice
game by Geoffrey Zhang here showing some
real opening understanding using this g4
idea using these sacrificial ideas in
the threats on b7 to improve his
position and then in this endgame some
very nice play pushing this pawn forward
gaining the material and then ensuring
that with this extra Bishop keeps the
black King out of play keeps pawns on
the boards and converts for the full
point thank you very much for joining me
on this episode of doing review my name
is Caleb den me and I will see you next
time